- Bladesmiths, this
the fuel can stab.
I'm gonna use your knives to
stab holes in these fuel cans
five times.
Remember, it's not what your
knives do to the fuel cans
but what the fuel cans
do to your knives.
Raleigh and Kelly,
you're up first.
Are you ready?
- Yes, sir.
Yes.
We're really excited
for the toughness test.
We fixed that point on it.
It's definitely stabbier.
And we're really excited
to see what's gonna happen.
[intense music]
[THUMPING FROM KNIFE PUNCTURES
ON CANS]
Raleigh, Kelly,
this is quite a knife.
It's got a nice point
for penetration.
But there's some chipping here.
The very point is still as sharp
as it was when you made it.
But there's no denying that was
a little chip on the edge here.
Joe, Casey you guys are up.
You ready?
Oh, yeah.
Let's do it.
CASEY: This is what me and
Joe live for, making knives
is testing them to destruction.
JOE: What's the use of
makin' somethin' if you can't
find out where it's limits are?
[intense music]
[THUMPING FROM KNIFE PUNCTURES
ON CANS]
Well, Joe, Casey, your
edge held up perfectly.
But this handle hurts.
What I ended up with was a
position that made my pinky
take a lot of the force.
The holes just needed to be
closer together and a little
taller.
But that edge, it's perfect.
- Thanks.
- Thank you.
Mark, Jessica, you ready?
Indeed.
Ben's ready to test our blade.
We know we've got that
cracking in there, something
that we did not address.
It's to the gods now.
[intense music]
[THUMPING FROM KNIFE PUNCTURES
ON CANS]
Well, Mark, Jessica, your
edge held up beautifully.
And those surface cracks we
saw in round one held together.
Well done on the handle.
This is the only one that I
could get my hand all the way
in and hold it with strength.
And it allowed me to
penetrate very deeply.
Overall, very well done.
That's quite a trench knife.
DAVID BAKER: All
right, bladesmiths,
to test the sharpness
of your blade,
this is all about with your
blades due to these fire hoses.
Raleigh, Kelly you ready?
Yes, sir.
[intense music]
[thud of hose being slashed]
[choow]
All right, Raleigh, Kelly,
you made a sharp knife.
There was no resis--
well, I can't
say there was no resistance by
the mark on my little finger
right there.
My little finger is
being pushed so far back
by that webbing right there.
If that were a little
bit further forward,
it might actually be
almost comfortable.
All right, Joe,
Casey, you're up.
You ready?
- Oh, yeah.
Let's do it.
DAVID BAKER: OK.
[intense music]
[thud of hose being slashed]
Good job.
Thanks.
DAVID BAKER: Joe, Casey,
beautiful, sharp edge.
I love the look of this.
That little finger is murder.
Man, I wish you had
spent a little bit more
time grinding out that ring.
All right, Mark,
Jessica, you ready.
Yes.
Indeed.
DAVID BAKER: OK.
[intense music]
[thud of hose being slashed]
- Oof.
Oh.
That is incredibly sharp.
I actually was through the hose
before I realized I'd hit it.
And those surface
cracks haven't opened up
or affected the performance
of your blade at all.
Let's get to your handle.
I can adjust this anyway I want.
The finger holes are big enough.
There's height in them.
Good job.
- Thank you so much.
Thank you.
WIL WILLIS: All
right, bladesmiths.
The judges have completed
their deliberation.
And they've made
a final decision.
It's time for one of these
teams to leave The Forge.
The team leaving The Forge is--
[intense music]
--Raleigh and Kelly.
Your blade did not make the cut.
Raleigh, Kelly, you guys
brought so much energy and fun.
It's not an easy challenge.
But at the end of
the day, there's
only one blade here that hurt
the user and took edge damage.
It's for this reason
your team is gone home.
WIL WILLIS: Kelly, Raleigh,
please surrender your blade.
I don't like it.
I don't like it when I don't
know how to do somethin'.
I'm goin' home.
I'm gonna make some
of them trench knives.
And I'm gonna be, like, the
queen trench knife maker?
What do ya think, Kel?
I think that I am just gonna
to work on regular knives.
[intense music]